Born from the minds of a New York comedy troupe
called The Tenderloins, Impractical Jokers
has been a reliable hit for TruTV since debuting
in December 2011.
Each episode consists of a series of challenges
and dares in which four friends bust each
other's chops by embarrassing one of their
own, usually in public, while hidden cameras
capture it all.
The goal: good-natured humiliation, all featuring
comic improvisation in a real-world setting.
"I'm gonna kill every one of yas!
You're all dead!"
After annual cruises, world tours, and the
embarrassment-themed TBS game show The Misery
Index, Joe, Murr, Q, and Sal are moving from
the small screen to the big screen when Impractical
Jokers: The Movie hits theaters on February
21st, 2020.
But what do you need to know before heading
in?
If you've watched the show, you know that
the average episode is constructed, but not
scripted.
The dares conceived by the Tenderloins force
them to use their improv skills in unusual
situations, both to make some good TV, and
to avoid a punishment at the end of the episode.
Impractical Jokers: The Movie takes the basic
concept of the series and blows it up to big-screen
levels.
The official synopsis?
"A humiliating high school mishap from 1992
that sends the Impractical Jokers on the road
in hidden camera challenges for the chance
to turn back the clock and find redemption."
The movie's December 2019 trailer shows that
this early '90s element is provided by '90s
superstar Paula Abdul, who meets the Jokers
and invites them to a big party in Miami…
but not all of them get to go.
They decide the best way to determine the
odd man out is to do what they always do:
stage elaborate, competitive scenarios in
which they can embarrass each other.
Whoever they collectively deem the loser of
this competition after ten events doesn't
get to go to Paula Abdul's party.
The trailer also gives a few sneak peaks at
some of the high-stakes humiliating situations,
including one of the Jokers crawling out of
a cave, resembling Gollum from The Lord of
the Rings.
"I've been down there since 1987, I was looking
for the gift shop."
They're also seen trying to get somebody to
help with a broken-down car with a trunk full
of drugs, and engaging in what appears to
be a horseback gladiator ride.
And Jokers fans will also appreciate Sal's
Jaden Smith tattoo making a cameo appearance
again.
All four members of the Tenderloins troupe
have co-written and co-headline the film:
Joseph Gatto, James Murray, Brian Quinn, and
Salvatore Vulcano.
You'll also spot producer and Inside Jokes
host Casey Jost.
The rest of the cast is filled out by both
actors playing people the Jokers meet during
their long voyage to Miami, and random strangers
who happen to get pulled into the group's
staged pranks.
At a 2018 San Diego Comic-Con event, Brian
Quinn stated that the movie consists of "80
percent hidden camera and 20 percent storyline."
However, some "name" actors do show up for
cameo appearances.
Expect to see Impractical Jokers : After Party
host and former NSYNC member Joey Fatone play
a street busker.
And Kane Hodder, the man in the Jason Voorhees
hockey mask in multiple Friday the 13th movies,
puts in an appearance as an imposing bodyguard.
If you want to catch up before the movie debuts
in February, the show's latest slate of episodes
debuts on TruTV on Thursday January 30th.
This ninth season will feature the 200th episode
of Impractical Jokers on February 13th, which
will be set in Los Angeles.
About a week later, Impractical Jokers: The
Movie will begin rolling out to theaters nationwide.
Unfortunately for those who want to know if
they should bring their kids, the MPAA has
yet to announce the film's rating.
That being said, there's no reason to expect
the Jokers' feature-length adventures to venture
too far beyond the bounds of all-ages entertainment.
We'll have to wait to find out for sure, but
the show's antics are in the PG-13 realm,
and fans should expect the same from the film.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.